From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
Hi, I'm Karen Keninger, Director
of the National Library Service
for the Blind and Physically
Handicapped.
We call it NLS.
I'm pleased to announce our latest
development, the NLS BARD Mobile app
for the iPhone, iPad and iPod touch.
The BARD Mobile app will let you
download and read NLS Braille
and talking books directly
from the NLS Braille
and Audio Reading Download
site we call BARD.
BARD contains nearly 50,000 books,
magazines and music scores in audio
and Braille formats, and the
collection grows every day.
With BARD Mobile, you
can play talking books
and magazines on your i-device.
You can also read WebBraille
books, magazines
and Braille music scores using
a refreshable Braille display
connected to your iPhone, iPad
or iPod touch through Bluetooth.
Before you can use BARD Mobile,
there are some things that you need
to have in place.First, you must
be registered with a Braille
and talking book library
in the NLS network.
If you aren't registered, check
out the eligibility
requirements at www.loc.gov/nls.
You may qualify for this service if
you can't read standard print due
to a visual or physical disability.
Second, you must establish
a BARD account.
Only registered NLS patrons
are eligible for BARD accounts.
Go to http://NLSBARD.loc.gov
and follow the instructions
to set up your account.
And third, you must
download the BARD Mobile app
through the app store.
It's free, but will only work
for people with a BARD account.
When that's done, you'll be
ready to log into BARD Mobile
with your BARD user
name and password.
You'll only need to do this
the first time you use the app.
The app has four tabs or
sections: Bookshelf, Get Books,
Now Reading, and Settings.
From the Get Books tab,
you can download materials
from your personal BARD wish list
and from the BARD recently
added books and magazines list.
You can also search
the BARD website.
When you find a title you want to
read, add it to your wish list.
Then you can download it from the
My Wish List section of the tab.
If you're using an iPhone,
we recommend downloading
over Wifi to save data charges.
Once your book is downloaded, go to
the Bookshelf, and select your book.
The Now Reading tab will open.
If the item you selected
is in audio format,
you'll find the same
basic layout you're used
to on the digital talking book
machine, with additional options
for navigation and information.
You'll find the Bookmark
button, the Menu button
which changes navigation levels, the
Previous and Next buttons to move
through the book or magazine, the
Fast Forward and Rewind buttons
for moving back and forward
by seconds or minutes,
and the Play-Stop button.
You'll also find controls to
adjust the speed and tone.
Just activate the Play button,
and begin listening
to your talking book.
If the item you selected
is in Braille format,
you'll find navigation
controls including the Previous
and Next buttons, a Menu button--
which allows you to skip through
the item by page, volume, bookmark,
and line, and a Bookmark
button to set bookmarks.
If you're using VoiceOver,
listen to the prompts
that are spoken each
time you touch a control.
They'll help you learn the
various gestures to use.
You can also find the BARD
Mobile on-line user manual
on your bookshelf.
The manual has more
in-depth help information.
That concludes our overview
of the BARD Mobile app.
For tips and tricks on
using the application,
check out our online video
series covering BARD Mobile.
Happy reading!
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.